LISA RAY: Hi, my
name is Lisa Ray,
and I'm on the Android
Developer Relations team.
Today I'm going to be
talking about the storage
API and Android 4.4.
So let's get started.
Before KitKat, you may
have seen or implemented
something like this.
You had ACTION_GET_CONTENT
or ACTION_PICK,
and you declared one
or more intent filters
in an activity in your manifest.
And this is what it looked like.
You would pick one
app, and you would
get one file back in your
original application.
In KitKat, we've introduced
a beautiful new picker
UI owned by the system.
You can browse content from
all apps, not just one.
You can see recent
files across all apps,
and you can search
within an app.
You can edit and
save files in place.
And it supports traditional
file hierarchies,
but it's flexible enough
for tag-based cloud storage.
And finally, it supports
multiple user accounts,
or transient roots, like
a USB storage provider,
where it should only show up
when the drive is plugged in.
In the storage API, we've
introduced two new intents,
OPEN_DOC and CREATE_DOC.
GET_CONTENT and PICK still work.
And we've got a new
permission, MANAGE_DOCUMENTS,
which only the system can hold.
So how to implement this.
First of all, in your manifest,
set your target SDK to 19.
Next, add your provider.
You provider name
in the manifest
is the name of your Java class
for your content provider.
Mine is called My
Cloud Provider.
Name your authority your
package named plus provider.
Your provider should
be exported because you
want other applications to
see it, namely the system.
Also, add the
MANAGE_DOCUMENTS permission.
By default, a provider
is available to everyone.
Adding the
MANAGE_DOCUMENTS permission
restricts your provider to the
system, important for security.
Also, we've added intent
filters to providers.
Make sure yours has the
DOCUMENTS_PROVIDER action
so it shows up when
the system searches
for document providers.
Here's a quick
picture of the flow.
As you can see,
providers and clients
don't interact directly,
just as before.
A client requests permission
to interact with files, read,
edit, create, et cetera.
The system picker goes to
each registered provider
and shows the user the
matching content roots.
One more note before we
get into the provider.
Usually with content
providers, you
have to make your own
contract document.
In this case, it's done for you.
All the constants for
fields you might return
and a lot of other
really useful methods
are in the class
DocumentsContract.
Here, these are
the columns we're
going to return in
the cursor when we're
queried for documents
or the root.
How you implement a provider.
You must extend
DocumentsProvider.
It's an abstract
class, and it has
a minimum of four methods
you must implement yourself.
They're called in this
order, queryRoots, followed
by queryChildDocuments,
and finally, possibly
either queryDocument
or openDocument.
There's many more,
but we're going
to start with the most
simple case, which
is just supporting openDoc.
Here's an example of what
happens when the provider first
queries the roots of all
documented providers.
The projection you
see is an argument,
just represents
the specific fields
the caller wants to get back.
ResolveRootProjection
is a method
that returns either those
fields or the full projection
if the caller passed in null.
So here, we're
creating a new cursor,
and we're adding one row to
it, one root, a top level
directory, like
gallery or drive.
Most applications
will have one root.
You might have more than one in
the case of, say, multiple user
accounts.
In that case, just add a
second row to the cursor.
The one thing that's
not given here
is GetDocumentId for a file.
Your implementation
is going to depend
on how you structure
your file storage.
What's important is that every
file, including directories,
have exactly one unique ID.
Other apps might
hold onto this ID,
and it's an explicit part of the
contract that it won't change.
Here's what shows up
when you query children.
This method gets
called when you choose
an application's root
in the Picker UI.
It gets the child
documents of a directory.
It can be called at every level
in the file hierarchy, not just
the root.
This sample implementation
is very simple.
It makes a new cursor with
the requested columns,
and then it adds information
about every immediate child
in the parent directory
to the cursor.
IncludeFile is very similar to
what we just saw for the root.
It adds the file display name,
MIME type, size, and so forth.
A child can be an image, another
directory, any type of file.
So queryDocument.
One or both of queryDocument
or openDocument
will get called when the
user selects a document.
QueryDocument returns
the same information
that was passed in
queryChildDocuments,
but just that specific
file, just the one of them.
OpenDocument returns a
parcel file descriptor,
which another application
can use to stream data.
You can see that we're
setting the access mode.
And the system takes care of
issuing URI permission grants
for us.
Those first four are enough to
get your content provider up
and running.
But there are a lot more
methods you can override.
Recent documents, search, add
thumbnails to your images.
Your implementation of these
may vary significantly,
depending on what kind of
back end you're running.
I'm not going to go
over them all here,
but there's a sample
implementation
of each of these methods in
the source code I'm posting.
One more thing,
security is often
a large issue when
you're sharing documents.
Suppose you 're a
password-protected cloud
storage service,
and you want to make
sure the user is
logged in before you
start sharing their files.
I'm assuming you
have some existing
method of
authenticating the user.
If not, I recommend
Google Plus Integration.
In any case, you're starting.
Your user is not logged in.
What you do in your
content provider
is to return zero roots, that
is, an empty root cursor.
This might be important
if your user had
been logged in
previously and you
had been providing a
root full of documents.
Now you don't want to.
The other step to
this is to call
getContentResolver.notifyChange.
Remember the documents contract?
We're using it to make this URI.
This tells the system to query
the roots of our provider
again, which will return
a different value now
because of the IF
statement we just saw.
So sample code and slides
will be available in-- look
at the description of
the video for a link.
Thanks for watching, and
let's share some documents.